und ich habe jetzt die gelegenheit mit
ina ruck zu sprechen schönen guten
morgen wir haben auf diese rede und auch
das was da in moskau passiert mit
enormer sensibilität geschaut
wie haben sie das interpretiert wir
zeigen gleich aus mitte noch einmal aus
der rede was da heute passiert ist
die rede selbst war fand ich sehr
ungewöhnlich für eine rede am 9 mai das
ist ja doch ein sehr wichtiger feiertag
hierfür viele wie es unserem alten lied
auch heißt ein feiertag mit mit
durchmischt mit tränen weil es doch auch
so ein gedenken ist an die vielen
weltkriegs toten an die gefallenen
soldaten aber auch all die anderen opfer
und diese rede heute war eine aggressive
die gleich in den ersten sätzen zum
einen die nato beschuldigt hat da in der
ukraine
quasi eine art angriff geplant zu haben
auf russland die gleichzeitig auch
sofort die
kämpfe das kriegsgeschehen in der
ukraine was ja hier offiziell keins ist
verbunden hat mit dem von damals es war
eine ganz ganz seltsame mischung wo sich
alles miteinander vermischt so bewusst
verschränkt wird also das war schon sehr
sehr auffällig das habe ich so nicht
erwartet es haben ja viele leute damit
gerechnet dass es heute eine art
kriegserklärung geben würde ich habe
immer gedacht dass das für diesen tag
nicht angebracht ist die hat es auch
tatsächlich nicht gegeben aber mit
dieser doch sehr aggressiven rede hat
putin den boden bereitet für so etwas
kann gut sein dass das demnächst kommt
wir haben uns heute morgen auch wir
hatten experten im studio gefragt was
wird da kommen können das ging ja bis
hin einige haben in den letzten tagen
gesagt da könnte ja heute auch mal eine
kleine eine taktische atombombe über der
ostsee gezündet werden als zeichen
sie sagen trotzdem es war eine
aggressive rede aber hat die gezeigt
wohin putin will
nicht so richtig aber sie hat schon noch
mal seine motivation sehr deutlich
gemacht er will die ukraine die ukraine
wurde mit keinem wort erwähnt
interessanterweise es ging immer nur um
den don bass das war sehr deutlich ja
die auch von präventivschlag oder previn
tiefschlag gesprochen er hat gesagt weil
man gewusst habe dass die nato der
westen da etwas plant habe man agieren
müssen das zeigt doch ganz klar man also
diese ukraine soll nach putins wünschen
nicht mehr existieren das ist sehr sehr
deutlich geworden heute eigentlich noch
einmal deutlich geworden wenn auch nur
zwischen den zeilen und die hoffnung die
ja manche hatten obwohl es auch eine
sehr vergiftete hoffnung eigentlich ist
dass er sich zufrieden gibt mit dem don
bass scheint meiner ansicht nach
nicht es gibt nicht viel anlass dazu ich
glaube er wird tatsächlich dass die
ukraine nicht mehr existiert ganz
ungewöhnlich stark hat er abgehoben auf
diejenigen die
opfer sind also russischer opfer sind
dessen was er da als befreiungskrieg
oder als befreiung deutlich macht er hat
jetzt von den schwer verwundeten
gesprochen von den ärzten die ihnen
helfen etc war das so ein bisschen auch
die vorbereitung dafür dem land russland
sagen zu müssen da ist ein krieg der
oder eine auseinandersetzung eine
befreiung die besondere opfer fordert
denn das ist ja in russland inzwischen
angekommen
ja gut möglich dass das genau der sinn
der sache war es war auch hier wieder
sehr überraschend manchmal wusste man
gar nicht mehr ging es so als er zu
anfang über die über das große leid der
gefallenen sprach dachte ich es geht um
die von 41 bis 45
plötzlich hat er dann gesagt dass es da
ja aber auch hilfen für die familien
gibt und es war dann sehr schnell klar
nein er meint die von heute dieses
verschränken miteinander die damals und
die heute kämpfen für dieselbe gute
sache das ist ja der sinn der sache soll
es glaube ich den angehörigen
hinterbliebenen heute leichter machen
und soll möglicherweise das land
vorbereiten dass da noch was kommt also
ich fand das auch sehr bemerkenswert
dass man anfangs gar nicht genau wusste
wen meint er denn jetzt und diese
verschränkung da so
gemacht hat das war glaube ich auch ein
sehr deutliches zeichen dafür dass er
dass da noch mehr kommen wird diese
verschränkung diese rhetorische die sie
erwähnen ist ja auch eine verschränkung
die ich schon darauf hindeutet dass da
noch was kommt was kommt denn da
möglicherweise wir interpretieren ja nun
so ein bisschen in der glaskugel im
augenblick das ist ja sehr schwer
abzuschätzen was erwarten sie persönlich
ganz schwer zu sagen ich hätte nie diese
entwicklung überhaupt erwartet heute
fand ich zwei dinge bemerkenswert dass
eine dass er dieses wort
präventivschlag oder es quasi so
umschrieben hat dass das nötig gewesen
sei das heißt also solche dinge gehören
in seinen instrumentenkasten offenbar
das fand ich sehr bemerkenswert und ich
fand noch mal bemerkenswert dass da so
durch schien es muss wirklich die ganze
ukraine sein fand ich sehr interessant
er hat übrigens ja auch im vorfeld den
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken alles gute
gewünscht zum sieges tag den regierungen
mit ausnahme der regierungen georgiens
und der ukraine
er hat sich aber an die ukrainische
bevölkerung und an die veteranen gewandt
und hat denen gewünscht es klang beinahe
zynisch an friedlichen himmel über den
köpfen und ein langes und gesundes leben
soll
heißen ihr gehört eigentlich zu mir und
eure regierung ignoriere ich also das
war sehr sehr deutlich
ganz herzlichen dank für die
informationen die analyse aus moskau
dankeschön